zoe curious why you wrote a story about
a 40-year-old actress who's struggling
for work in hollywood
um well it doesn't seem like a very um
unusual story
no you know i am
i think for me personally
writing is parts of my life and parts of
my life so i although this movie doesn't
exactly pertain to the person that i am
it definitely has
feelings of who
i am or what this age brings to me and
what i'm noticing about myself and about
others and so i thought hollywood was a
really interesting metaphor place to
like set a stage because it's so about
this kind of outside look and what you
look like and how thin you are and how
perfect you can be and this this
striving for perfection that's so
um
i know it scares me a little bit because
it's not really who i am i like the kind
of messy parts of life and so i thought
this would be a really good way of
describing
what it's like to have all those
pressures on you as a as a 40 year woman
and if you before you completely accept
that you are
past a certain age you're still fighting
for that youthful moment and how do you
find that balance and make it serve you
the best way
right and it reminds me of the
documentary
searching for deborah winger where there
were various hollywood actresses
interviewed about you know getting older
in the industry and i think they talked
about that gray area where once you're
like what 35 to maybe 50-ish there's
very few roles that you can play maybe
once you're past that 50 mark there's
more sort of grandmother or maternal
type roles
what's your experience been with that in
terms of casting for your own films and
talking to other actresses about that
gray area that this film seems to be
about
well
you know i don't think we're ever aware
of our age until we're that age and then
it all becomes all too you know
there
um
i think about you know it's funny i
think about my mom and
my mom had some of her best roles ever
in her whole life or anyone's life in
her 40s and her 50s and it's because my
dad
saw something in her that was a very
vital woman that had
there was a certain understanding of the
complexities of when you get older and a
woman over 40 because we're full of all
kinds of interesting things that you
know maybe we weren't 10 or 20 years ago
so yeah i talk about it a lot with
different actresses
because i'm interested i'm interested in
writing parts for
i mean i'm not just specifically
interested in writing parts for women
but i like writing parts women because
i'm a woman and i see what they go
through and i it's an interesting
exploration so
so um
yeah i think everybody's very concerned
i think that there is like a building
consciousness about it that people
men and women alike are starting to feel
the imbalance of it and starting to
if not fight for at least wish for some
movies about you know these women in
these these ages
zoe what would your advice be to
other actresses over 40 who
they're creative they're vibrant they
want to still go on they don't want to
hide their head under the covers but at
the same time they know the realities
they know all the digs that
people throw their way
well
i think it's
i mean i think it's pretty obvious what
it is that being an actor is to me it
would have been a horribly frustrating
job because you have to wait you have to
wait for someone to accept you have to
wait you have to put all your faith and
all your whatever into someone else's
decision and that would drive me bananas
so
i see a lot of really great really
talented actresses writing parts with
themselves now or co-writing parts or
directing things and moving into
production on the other side to make
sure that they have the parts that they
want
and it's really really really
interesting um
i just reading a story in the new york
times about amanda pete it was exactly
the same thing she turned 40 years old
she could she had a great career that
kind of petered out into this place
where she was kind of lost in this age
group and she wrote a play for herself
that ended up she ended up giving the
part away to sarah jessica parker
because she thought she was a better i
mean
she didn't think she was a better fit
but she thought she was great and she
thought oh my god i can have this woman
and she can portray this and i can be
the writer so she stepped back and she
let herself
you know
be a different part but be a creative
and i think that happens with you know
in movies and you see a lot more female
directors now and i think
you know i think and i think directors
just need to take a little more care
about females you know whether they're
woman director or man director you know
so
you even said i think something similar
for female filmmakers that if they kind
of have a quirky niche or style to them
they're accepted or else they can go
into what what is it called the girl
ghetto which is all of the documentary
filmmakers that are female but in terms
of being a narrative filmmaker it's a
little you said there's there's its own
sort of stereotypes with that as well oh
yeah i well i mean you know we as women
we're constantly
men are constantly hoping that we're
going to make chick flicks and you know
so women will go men don't have to go
but you can still make the right amount
of money that you can because you've
made a chick flick and
and that's fine i love chick flick
but i also
love a serious movie and i don't think
that
there's i mean i don't think there's
enough dramas actually directed by women
you know thank god for mira nair who
decides to make you know real serious
narrative movies but if you think about
it we're all kind of
regulated into this like we're a woman
and we're working and then we're going
to find love and we're going to lose it
but we're going to get it back and then
we're going to realize that we're
probably not really good about working
we should rather be just happy in love
you know and that's
you know a little offensive
but we laugh but there's some truth to
it yeah i mean
it's called irony
so you did a great interview on the
huffpost live that i watched and you
said that so many people see the end
result of films the walking the red
carpet all dressed up and and it looks
so wonderfully easy what would you want
people to know about this project and
all of the hard work you're doing behind
the scenes
well i mean i i don't really think i
think that knowing for the general
audience knowing too much about the
blood sweat and tears go on behind the
scenes would kind of lessen the movie
magic experience for people but i think
that they're
when the criticism comes in about oh
well you just do that and you just so
easy to do that and you're so lucky
because you have that or blah blah blah
blah
there is so much work and there's so
much disappointment and there's so much
insecurity and there's so much
you know fighting but fighting this good
cause and getting very like excited
about it and then going downhill because
it doesn't then you have your time
you're your own you know captain of your
ship
and
i mean making an independent movie is a
very complicated thing at any time but
in this time especially and they say oh
well you know you can shoot it on 5d and
you can do this yeah sure i can do all
of these things and i will do all of
these things but i shouldn't just be you
know regulated to like
i don't know an independent film is a
really you know it's
independent film means
very little money it means
but very little money often leads to
much more creativity and that's what i'm
interested in i'm not interested in the
kind of a general story i want to fight
the good fight i want it to get ugly and
i want i think people want that you know
but it's not especially doing things
uglier especially doing things
out of the general realm of how you know
that people can't say oh well i saw that
and that must be like that so then i can
watch this and
it's you know it's about taking a chance
and you know
so it's a lot of struggle
and you know i
if i had the check to write out my own
movie i would absolutely do it you know
a few months ago
not now but you know i'm an independent
filmmaker and i come from an independent
film family where we all
you know work really hard to make the
art and get to struggle and you know
sometimes you're broke and sometimes you
have money and
you know that's the way it goes but
there's nothing secure about it you
really have to be kind of like
strong and you know it's a really
strange life but
also it's such a rewarding life that you
take the good with the bad
well speaking of independent film and
sort of the grittiness and ugliness that
goes along with it with this film for
day out of days do you think the topic
of invisibility in hollywood is a little
too
is like that elephant in the room people
don't want to talk about it maybe is
that too scary whereas
i would love to see it a lot of
independent film people i think would
love to but maybe the mainstream yeah
who cares let them get mad that means
something's going on you know it's just
if you touch somebody and you make them
angry it's almost like a very opposite
but close to making them very happy so
if you've done that then you sparked
something inside somebody a debate
inside somebody and as a as a filmmaker
that's all you kind of hope to do you
know is touch somebody in a way
so go for it yeah well you said you like
stories about pain
and not in the way that you like to see
people transcend through them i'm not
talking about like 24 the movie i'm
talking about you know right and
transcend and maybe they're not they
don't go to that you know perfection but
that they're at an okay place what is it
about that that's so fascinating to you
and why do you think we all like to see
it i think we're all
as humans
i think there's two things or maybe it's
just me but it's very sometimes shocking
to realize that your
pain and your insecurity and fears are
very very very connected to other people
in the world who also feel that their
pain and insecurity is very singular so
when you can reach out i always say when
i'm writing and it's really hardcore i
call it the cringe moment like
and it's about you know i can use the
worst part of me in it and i'm like
that's going to be the part that
everybody's going to like because
everybody's going to be able to relate
to something that
is unsaid
but needs to be articulated you know so
i think
finding a journey with somebody
is very important to your own journey
and how you can
live through other people but how you
can learn something about you know
yourself and not maybe not be as ashamed
about it or maybe find something really
interesting about it that you wouldn't
necessarily feel if you were just by
yourself you know and isolated
who do you think the audience is
for day of days
well
i don't want to just be like the woman
director who makes movies for women i
mean i will be but i mean i think that
there is
i mean i go to see movies about men all
the time so i don't see why men
shouldn't go see a movie about a woman
who's struggling or you know there's men
in the movie if they're really bored by
it but i mean i just think that um
the audience should be
i know i got an email from a friend of
mine who's a young actress and she was
talking about the movie and she said
it affected her the idea affected her so
much because it was what she might
become and i hadn't even thought about
that i was so in the moment with this 40
year old actress that i hadn't thought
about i mean of course the elders they
all know what was what had come but the
the ones had not had seen the future and
i never thought about that kind of
audience so i thought that was really
interesting to see a younger people
projecting on to
what might be able what might become of
them
so
you know i i'm hoping for
anyone who likes
you know
movies to go check it out and god i hope
it's good
yeah it's a funny thing about youth we
look at people that are older than us
and think that they were just always
like that we don't realize that they
were one you know that that someone had
said that to me a long time ago because
you you just don't envision that they
were once your age as well they were
just always
it's shocking it's almost more shocking
to look at older people and realize that
they were once your age then look at
someone who's younger and then you will
become me you know
but uh no it's true and it's it's
you know we have to accept this i mean
there's such ageism problems in the
world i don't want to see the movie
about old people you know and and you
know but there there's a vitality that i
guess as you get older you realize you
will carry that vitality through your
entire life
and whether you're you know
40 or 80 you still have that weird i
mean i talk to people all the time or
like i feel like i'm 19. or i'm i'm a
friend who's 83 and she said i'd kill to
be 60 again and i was like
oh okay okay there's some perspective in
it so you know you just have to
enjoy your life and make the things that
you want you know
zoe why did you choose fund anything
over kickstarter
well um
a friend of mine who is working for fund
anything approached me about um doing a
campaign over there and i didn't really
you know i was probably like most of the
world like kind of
heard about the idea of crowdfunding
like in the back of your ear and what it
was and but i had no idea what the
specifics that were or anything so i did
i listened to what he had to say i did a
little research with indiegogo and
kickstarter which and i found them all
pretty having similar
platforms but since my friend kind of
personally drew me in to find anything
i found myself a kind of more attractive
to them because it seemed more personal
but then they
i mean i don't have any really other
experience with crowdfunding sites but
they were so um involved they helped us
out they got on the phone with us they
worked things out they told us when they
thought things weren't good and i heard
from other
people that kickstarter and indiegogo
they just kind of like
put you out there and hope you make it
you know
so i really appreciated the personal
attention from them they're really
lovely people and they're trying to do
something which i think all of them are
they're trying to help artists in this
kind of
no artist help society
to be really eloquent about it um
they're trying to do something to make
the public aware you know i was talking
about everybody becoming this patron of
the of the arts you know and we need
this in the country it can't just be
about like you know texting and video
games and what you can watch on itunes i
mean it's just
the world has gotten to be this like you
know
very it's like dulling itself around the
edges i think and
if we're going to do stuff to shake it
up again i think that people need to get
involved in what they like and what they
can see and they can support and they
can override this kind of no no no no no
society no that's too much of a risk no
that's two things no it's about a woman
no that's did you know that jus the
people holding
the purse strings you know so it's like
i've been looking for this revolution
for a long time and i think this is
you know i don't think kickstarter's i
mean i don't think crowdfunding is the
end all of what but i think it's an
option and i think it's a great option
but it's an enormous amount of work and
it's a real kind of trial by error thing
the first time you do it because who
could you know i'm i'm a 40 plus year
old woman that wasn't really my
generational thing but at the same time
now i know and i'm part of that new
generation and i know what it is and i'm
not just like ah turn down the music
it's too loud you know like you know
because
but you know what i mean it's it's a you
become involved with stuff and you know
about it and that that way you stay in
touch with this new generation you don't
necessarily have to use it all the time
but instead of kind of closing yourself
off to the future or the present
you become a part of it and i think
there's
you know and i think there's incredible
generosity this incredible support from
people who are interested you know
in you or
you know and say things and kind of
either support you or give money to you
or
just to look and see what you're doing
and i think that there's something you
know
very
i don't know
warm about it in a way you know that
that's not so warm sometimes when you're
looking for money other ways
well what were some of the things that
they told you at fund anything like did
they give you a list of bullet points of
do's and don'ts because they did they
did and you know of course you know
being the rebel that i am like i'm not
doing this and i'm not going to do this
and i'm doing this this way you know and
they're like okay whatever you want to
do but then at the end i'm like okay
that's not working what should i do and
they were like well okay and they helped
out and so
that's great you know i tend to be a
very like you know i guess when you come
from independent cinema
and you're the youngest child
you end up like never asking anybody for
help i'm very bad at asking people for
help and this was the ultimate
ask for help you know putting yourself
out there putting yourself online it's a
very vulnerable thing to do in a way
but uh
it helped me get over like those kind of
fears about it you know whether you
completely succeed or crash and burn you
have to do something it's like a call to
action you know i'm making a movie with
a basically an unknown actress i'm
making a movie about
something they can't figure out where
like how to financially make it like is
that going to be successful you know
there's a lot of i'm making about
hollywood i'm making you know and it's
this kind of it's kind of scathing and
so there's all these things like
completely like
people aren't really like oh
great
so i mean i like a challenge but i think
this is
what i want to do and i think alexia is
the best person for the job and so
doing this crowdfunding and stating it
out there in the world doesn't allow
someone to say oh well who else you
could use this star instead of her you
can do it's like this is what i'm doing
you like it go for it you don't like it
that's okay movies aren't made for
everyone
but this is what i'm doing and don't
change it
and so i finally got to find my voice
and be very strong in my voice and what
i wanted out of it so i felt that that
was
you know all different kinds of things
came out of just going into the action
of this crowdfunding which i thought was
really really
interesting and
motivating and telling
what were some surprises i mean i know
you have four days left as of the taping
of this video what were some surprises
that you you weren't aware of either
positive negative whatever just
epiphanies you had about this whole
process
well
what's really sweet about like the
funding is like people come out of the
woodwork that you wouldn't expect to and
it's like the most touching thing you
could ever see in your life you know
like my accountant or the guy my dry
cleaner or something like they know me
and they have a relationship with me
they want to see me succeed and i just
think that that kind of thing is like
you shake your head and like wipe a tear
away from your eye because
you don't it's unexpected you know
and
so there's things like that and
uh and it's like you know i'm kind of
not the most
i mean i'll do the social network i just
don't know if i'm doing it right you
know so there's but there's a lot of
contact with people
and with different people reaching out
from different areas of filmmaking to
fans to friends and so
you start to just have a reconnection
with people and
gosh
you know i've been living in paris for
the last six years and um
i felt a little bit off the grid coming
back to america i got to be honest you
know and so it was a great way of
remembering and reconnecting and
becoming becoming part of society again
in this kind i mean it is a strange
society that people belong to and
instead of being always on the outside
like i'm too indie or i'm too this or i
don't need to talk to anyone it's like
no i need to talk to a lot of people and
i need to keep talking to a lot of
people for business for motivation for
food like you know intellectual food and
so
being someone that doesn't like to ask
for help and i
know that affliction very much
how do you get to cross out of that
comfort zone where you do because
crowdfunding is so much about
i don't know i don't even remember how i
got i just remember starting to prepare
for crowdfunding and not really
questioning it and then all of a sudden
i was like
i was so nervous excuse me i was so
nervous on the first day i was like i
was like kathy you know that cartoon
with like the tears coming out of my
eyes like oh i don't know what to do
and
you know
as long i didn't you know spontaneously
combust that day no one you know threw
stones at me i lived through that day
and others and so
you know i i think in this world i was
thinking about it the other day it's
like you don't know how to do anything
without practicing and you're not you
can't be good at anything without
practicing how to do it and honing your
skills on any every level you know
including asking for help so sometimes
you need to get thrown in the pool
in order to figure out you know
how to deal with it and how to ask for
something and you know i get so
frustrated because i'm like nobody
and then someone said well you don't ask
for anything how does anyone know that
you need help and i thought
yeah
you know
so
you know you're constantly working on
yourself trying to figure out how to
get better at stuff you know
zoey what's your impression of the
celebrity machine you've obviously been
around it enough to know
the ins and the outs of it
it's a tough question i mean as
probably most people in the world i have
an obsession and an interest in it as
more of a voyeur probably than to be in
it
i don't
i think it's gotten a little out of
control i think i mean i it's i think
it's gotten out of control i feel sorry
for people like
you know they
there's too many events and there's too
much hair and makeup and there's too
much you know and there's there's just
that attention drawn away from the work
to be put into this kind of distraction
of and i don't i mean i you know fashion
and film and all that perfect it goes
together for sure
but
it's about for me it's about
i don't know
that kind of thing isn't for me you know
i like what i do i like being behind the
camera i hate this stuff you know it
doesn't uh
it doesn't thrill me
but i do it because part of my job but
um
i mean i think some people handle it
remarkably
i mean you know we can't all be george
clooney but uh
he's so graceful you know and there's
there's there
but it's such a machine and it must be
i was actually thinking about angelina
jolie the other day and thinking how
tired she must be
she goes here she goes to un she goes to
afghanistan she's got six kids she makes
a movie she directs movies she has a
surgery she's a thing and she looks
amazing and she looks amazing and you
think i don't know how for me i wouldn't
be able to do that and i think some
people handle it really well i think
it definitely there's probably a lot of
pressure in that for those people to
stay on this and that's what the movie
is about it's like how do you stay
at this level that people expect you to
stay at how you stay in this perfection
and always say the right things and
always do the right things and always
make the right choices in your work and
the right choices in love and your whole
life is on display
and it just
it must be exhausting you know so i
think that's and i think it's a very
certain time in um
society and that is this kind of
celebrity and this i mean this is what
my movie is about is it's just how do we
get to this place and how is you know
the
the outside of it more important than
what's like the soulfulness of it and
it's so imbalanced and how do you how do
you find your balance in an imbalanced
world
basically
right that being said how do you do
your own promotion because it's so
necessary for the campaign and i know it
almost feels like this sort of shameless
like salesmanship
thing but but that it's got to be
difficult if
you have those values which i i totally
get to then have to sell yourself for
what what is it a 45 day campaign or how
what's my campaign
i'm not selling anybody else's so you
know if i don't if i don't sell it you
know
i want to do something there are
necessary
measures to get to where you need to go
sometimes and some of them are
uncomfortable i mean i wouldn't do
something that i completely didn't
believe in or thought was awful or it's
like against everything i you know and
my heart believed him but
you know you got sometimes you gotta
you know get out there and
sling sling
it going back to the whole celebrity
machine
what do you want people to take away
once they see day out of days about the
main character about her struggle what
do you what do you want them to see
um i don't know i don't really
i wouldn't dictate that i think a story
is a story and everybody that's what's
great about reading a book or seeing a
piece of art or watching a movie or
seeing a photograph is everybody finds
their own relation to it so
i would never tell anybody what to think
about it in fact i'd rather you tell me
what you thought about it and how it
would relate to you i know how it
relates to me
and i know how the story relates to me i
know how the story relates to alexia and
i feel that if we put as much truth into
the story and as much 100 percent and
try to not give a false note then
everybody is going to have you know
their own opinion about it take away
whether they hated it or loved it or you
know
whatever and i think that to me that
subjectiveness is so exciting because
you
are so specific about how what you want
to say and what you want to say and then
i mean as a writer you know and then you
give it to the actors and then the
actors say
oh what about this and you're like oh my
god that's amazing because i never
thought of that because i'm that close
to it and then they bring something you
have to allow everybody to bring
stuff to the to the
to the film
because that's how the collective
consciousness of the film gets born you
know so
whether they hated it and want to throw
you know cabbages at the screen
to me that's a reaction and i say you
know
go for it you know i just want people to
see the movie and i want to make the
movie and i want it to feel
good you know
and your main character does she have a
love interest
i am so excited that this well she has a
love interest just that that in that
person isn't interested in her he just
doesn't know it yeah no she doesn't this
movie isn't centered around like a man
validating who you are which i think is
really interesting i you know i mean i'm
definitely into like love stories and
finding yourself and being able to find
love but i already explored that issue
and i think this is more about
you know i i don't know when you're in
school and the english teacher tells you
like there are five stories there's man
versus nature there's man versus man
there's man versus himself and
this is a real man versus himself movie
about
somebody who
had a moment
got lost for whatever reason we all do
at certain times lost her way and is
struggling to find their way back but
not the way back that's offered but the
way back that's truly
your way back what's going to help you
continue in your life and make you have
a happy life
so
is it about also being seen in the world
when she feels invisible yes i mean i
think actors definitely i mean people
who want to be actors want to be seen
let's not be you know coy about it you
know i think
but i i mean i must want to be seen in a
way too by by writing and giving certain
parts of myself that are not necessarily
portrayed by me on screen but you know
through
and i think
you know i think there's nothing wrong
with being seen or being want to be seen
it's just the extremity of it now is so
shocking you know there's nothing
left to there's no mystery left in the
world and
i think that you know i come from a
generation
before this new generation who i mean
who all know that there's only facetime
and texting and things that you know
never looking for like running home to
check their machine to see if there's a
message from the boy they love or
whatever you know i mean there's a
certain romance that we had that before
that was about discovery
and now discovery is every second you
know and so
it's interesting to find and i mean for
me to find an actress who's not so well
known you don't know her whole history
when you go when you're watching her on
screen which i think is really
interesting
and just to sit back and follow a real
story of someone's
ups and downs is you know
it's important i think it's important
i'm not saying my movie's important but
i'm saying it's important to hear human
stories and be able to relate to them in
this time where there's
this kind of
mechanical
you know
accoutrement to everything
everyone has a selfie on online
somewhere yeah i don't even know what
all these they they're always saying
like lfmo or something like that i don't
know what any of those things mean and
that's when i started to feel really old
how long have you been trying to get
this film made in a traditional manner
before you went to
fund anything it goes through so
many
steps i think you know you have an idea
i wrote a script really fast i wrote the
script really fast which is actually not
this particular script but it was the
original script of how i started and
i wanted to write a comedy and i thought
if i write a comedy it'll be really easy
and you know
wrong
so
i think there's a question of
it's a big process trying to find money
because it's everyone who wants to give
you money has an opinion about a script
as they should because they're giving
you money and
um so there's that and then
i don't know people like it they don't
like it i was living in a different
country i had to come to america i'd
come to los angeles to kind of focus on
that so that was like even a year after
of trying to kind of have meetings and
go back and forth and
i mean my last home took four years to
be able to make and
it's it's not an uncommon story among
around filmmakers um so this has been
a couple of years but then i did a
really big script change and which i
think is
way better it's not a comedy anymore
it's kind of a movie about something
it's got funny parts in it but it's not
uh comedy
and so
you know i i was thinking about this too
and i was thinking about how great
crowd how a great idea
and effective crowdfunding can be
because sometimes you write a script and
four years pass and you become a
different person in that time and none
of those things really make sense and
then okay you could go back and rewrite
but there's something if you have an
idea and you can have the immediacy of
making it in that time it becomes a full
thought instead of like this constant
broken up where you have to become like
you have to put down your artist hat and
you have to put on your producer hat and
you have to go in and you have to get
money and like that's fine it's all part
of the thing but it's distracting from
each other
so once you you can never get back on
the roll and so
it takes a while it takes a while it
takes much longer than people think and
you know in the meantime like hopefully
get some other jobs to pay for your life
and um
and you keep going
what were some of the notes you received
from the different investors that you
went to did they want you to change it
oh can you make her 30 years old instead
of four i mean like what were some of
the things they said to you
i don't care to talk about that i think
everybody
sure has a valid thing but until
you know i have my own reasons and i
don't like when people give you notes
without asking you why
it doesn't make sense to me it's like oh
i don't like that and you think well i
could tell you why that was the reason
then we can really have a discussion
about it so
i think some people are better than
giving notes some people are absolutely
no there are kind of maybes there's a
lot of waiting around for people to read
scripts and stuff like that so
you have to i say pick a group of people
maybe five that you really trust who
really know you
some of them can be in the film industry
some hopefully ones like a dentist or
somebody works out of the industry or
something
to get the full spectrum of like notes
like i don't understand this why does
this happen and so i instead of like
people and people are nice they ask can
i read your script and you get all
excited about it because it feels
validating and then you know but then
you've subjected yourself to 49 opinions
where you don't need 49 opinions you
need five
so
you know it's all about collaboration
i'm all about collaboration stuff but i
think it's uh
you have to be
smart and
and also my advice would be be very very
very sure about your script before you
send it out because you really only get
one chance and that kind of thing unless
you're like me and rewrote your script
but
so you just have to have patience you
have to have real conviction you know
and how long is your campaign 30 days 30
days okay and is it correct that then if
you make your goal that it's being
matched i think i saw that on the side
or we have a lot of yes we we have
matching goals we have matching funds we
have you know this is very helpful to us
in many many different ways so
not just for the money but for the
attention and for the aware and more
attention but the awareness that this is
happening like i was saying like i'm
doing this
we're doing it this way get on board you
know
and uh the trains leaving the stage
train's leaving the station you need a
ride get on board
is it easy being a second generation
filmmaker with all the expectations and
people's opinions about whatever it is
you know
it's very hard to answer that question
because that's where i came from and i
didn't come from somewhere else so i
don't really know the difference between
is it easy i mean is anybody's family
like particularly awesomely easy some
people i guess but
i mean i live in a in a family of
artists who all are you know we're up
and down and thing but no i mean yes yes
no
yes no i mean
it gives people
i i i got the best lesson i got the best
film school i got i got movies made in
my house i got to see
a way of making films from my parents
that was a style that i could relate to
which was very grassroots very like
everybody come together and let's do
something great not like let's do it for
the money or let's do you know it was a
very the intention was so pure you know
and that time was so
influential to me as
a writer and director yes but it's
something that i wanted like
that style that family that feeling that
i wanted and it felt so right and so
comfortable so
that part is so great and you know
i don't know i mean people are very
critical you know and they expect you i
don't you don't make as good as movies
as john cassavetes he's like well i only
made one movie can i get to make more
movies and maybe
you know you'll like more of my movies
because i was talking about there's that
experience that you have to have you
keep learning you keep getting better
you keep and you have to have the
ability i mean
to be able to make them you know people
need to help you make these films so you
can show you know it's a big circle so
i mean yes and no yes no yes no
what would your advice be to someone
else who's of a second generation film
acting creative family where they need
my advice i've been through their
they you know they they know what it's
all about if you're born into it you
you know what it's all about it's nice
to maybe come together and relate for a
second but i mean
there's such awesome things about it and
there's really shitty things about it
and you know
obviously we're not out there like
advertising all the shitty things you
know about it but
you know i would say like it's the key
that opens the door but you gotta turn
the doorknob you know well you're still
human beings so you still have to go to
functions and you still have to put your
work out there so you talked
in another interview about being the
cheerleader of your own project so
knowing that there are pressures
how do you be that you know in that what
are you doing to beat your own drum so
to speak it's a bad metaphor but what
what are you doing because i'm sure that
it is difficult
and there are
expectations or people's jealousies
whatever
i mean whatever it's like people are so
jealous not jealous and people say awful
things they tweet you awful things they
send facebook thing awful things awful
things they say awful things to you
about who they think you are
and how why are you doing this and you
should come from a rich you come from a
family does it look like my family made
a lot of trust fund movies i mean i mean
did you ever see a movie of my parents
you know i mean it's like there's no
so there's all these perceptions about
how glamorous and how much money you
have and how it's like i've been
supporting myself for many many years
you know i had real jobs i worked i did
everything so
there's that you know but you have to
let that go and you have to be like
you know people are either people always
going to think what they want to think
and you can you know raise your hands
and scream and light yourself on fire
and say i'm not that person and they are
going to believe you're not so i don't
really worry about that so much
um
although
it does kind of get you down sometimes
because you're just kind of trying to
fight the good fight but um
you know if you want to do something
you should you have to realize that the
criticism is out there too
so it's a balance i think the quote is
like i think does it terry cole whitaker
wrote a book what other people think of
me as none of my business
that's a good one yeah you need to read
that book okay i think i'll read it too
let's read it to each other okay
zoey why are there so few stories about
women in mainstream films
in your opinion
because women are the ultimate powerful
people and men want to keep them down
i don't know i think
maybe it has to do with i think
in the world women are i mean
let me start that over
i think the world is changing a lot and
i think women are become gaining more
and more power in the world and i think
even from the 50s even from you know
50 years ago i mean it's a completely
different world we as women we work we
run home we're like you know
i can bring home the break and fry it up
in a pan you know and never let you
forget your man but
but no really i mean it's women are very
powerful we're doing things we're
putting ourselves in power positions you
can you can go have a baby by yourself
if you want to men i mean it's a very
different
world and maybe
we're just trying to figure out what
that world is and
get out of the man
powered base and make it more equal but
you know i think people are kind of
discovering what their roles in life are
right now
and um
i think there are more and more movies
about women i think there's more of a
consciousness that there aren't
a lot of movies about that or that the
women are put in these kind of side
roles
and i think people are getting mad about
it because that's not really how the
world is now
women aren't getting put in these side
roles as much we are
equals or becoming equals and um
and it seems unfair so i think the world
that you know
i think it happens all the time we
recalibrate and we figure it out and
then you know maybe it's a hard time to
make independent films or whatever but
they'll be
you know a group of them that go for it
and get out there and it'll be these
transformative films that make it so
that there's a new way of being able to
make films and a new way to talk about
stuff and you know it's just a constant
evolution so i think
the more we can support that i'm sure in
20 years from now this will be an
obsolete conversation
you know
so what have been the typical films
about women if if they're
the main stars in the film i mean you
know
the 90s and to now that there's really
not that women-centric film i mean you
had all these shirley maclaines and
meryl streep and everybody in these ann
bancroft and general rollins and you
have these amazing women doing amazing
parts all the time and maybe they were
half the man and thing but they weren't
ever the you know
even
you know you think like it's not even
his girl friday or something it's like
even though that's a really powerful
role from the 20s to the 30s the 40s
50s got a little weird 60s were back 70s
80s 90s and then in the 90s
it just turned into something else
and so
i think we just have to get back get out
of that you know and rhythm and get back
into a new rhythm
so you'd like to see female characters
that are
a whole person not just a quirky you
know thelma and louise let's go on this
sort of you know even though wonderful
phone i enjoyed that but um yeah no it
just yes i would i'd like to see all
characters more well-rounded not just
women all characters i would like to see
you know
what makes someone tick in a movie why
what the motivation is
and um
you know i think
we need everybody needs to pay a little
bit more attention to the scripts
so when you wrote uh the main character
for day out of days
what what poured out of you like did you
see this person in your mind this is
did you see this woman and what was it
that just you said you wrote it so
quickly i did i i know a lot of
actresses i tried to be an actress when
i was younger i was terrible at it but
at least i had the experience and
the humiliation of it so
um
i just thought what it was
was just such a tough
place you know to be
and
it fits so well with that idea about
aging you know god forbid we're old at
40 but you know if 40 is the new 30 it's
like something i wrote it's like but
it's not the new 30 in hollywood and
it's not the new 30 in life
i mean we feel this vitality but
you know
it's something you still have to fight
against fighting the fighting the clock
always fighting the clock
so what what about that story and that
this character really poured out of you
i mean also too and not just ageism but
also you have to be like this perfect
little hostess i think a lot of times
and and in terms of
you know meeting people and of course
you want to be cordial but i think
there's the pressure to
to be that as well
oh it's off i mean it's awful i hate
being put on the spot in those
situations personally so
i think
it's about someone who has to kind of
break their own egg you know
and
it's it's so easy to put the layers on
it's so easy for me for a lot of people
in the world just to put the layers on
and not ask the important questions and
not take the scary chances and
ultimately not be happy and fulfilled in
life very easy
much harder to take all the chances
break the egg and find some sort of you
know happiness